you're live
CH good evening and welcome to the
overview and scrutiny committee meeting
on Thursday the 7th of December
2023 my name is councelor Simon Morgan
and I'm the chairperson of this
committee members we are streaming this
meeting live as well as recorded and by
being present in the meeting you are
giving your consent to being recorded
during each item please put your hand up
to indicate if you wish to speak I will
then invite you at the appropriate time
could I ask members to avoid approaching
the top table as this could create
interference with the cameras and live
stream please note that the YouTube live
stream sound recording is dependent on
the correct use of the microphones
therefore can I ask that when invited to
speak you remember to turn on your
microphone and turn it off when finished
finished please reference a page or
paragraph number when referring to the
agenda papers and keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible so uh moving on apologies for
absence uh do we have any apologies uh
burner yes yes chairman we apologies for
absence from councelor Hughes thank
you and okay uh moving on item three the
uh minutes of the last
meeting um the those obviously been
circulated to members have any members
any particular
comments uh well I actually do have one
and that is regarding the process
Improvement framework which I believe
we're now part of what what's happened
about I don't haven't heard hide or hair
or anything about
it I haven't heard anything anything
further either either it is on my list
of things to do very long list um to
find out well what next what happens now
so yes that's with me I suppose to do
that okay thanks I'm glad you right okay
uh moving on then uh public
participation and there's no public
participation as far as I'm aware is
that right vill no
no
okay sorry just one second
moving councelor white I'm sorry I I
should have brought you welcomed you to
our our committee at the first good to
see you here thank you chairman and I
was just asking if it was okay if I
could comment on oh well obviously you
can put your hand up the appropriate
time thank you very
much right in fact I think uh oh sorry
Stevens yes I might have missed it I
know we just had that word about what
was happening next on that butth did we
actually agree the minut of the meeting
ah good point anyone right is those
minutes agreed yes
thanks right so moving on to agenda item
six scrutiny work plan item planning
decision- making and the report on pages
to4 and uh this will be presented by Mr
Jennings Mr Jennings over to you good
evening um this matter on the scrutiny
work plan um has been uh uh looked at by
the committee for getting on for a year
now
um and the committee previously made uh
some recommendations to council which
were accepted and have been implemented
but arising from the early consideration
by the committee
um there were one or two other matters
um left unattended you might say and the
committee has since picked that up and
given it detailed consideration um both
at a previous meeting of the committee
and at least two meetings of its working
group um and these two matters involve
firstly um the the introduction of what
has been become known as a
constitutional intervention or break uh
but quite simply that means introducing
something into the
Constitution that enables as a matter of
course and as a matter of procedure or
there to be a a deferment when in
consideration of a planning
application at a planning committee
members are minded to overturn the
recommendation of the officers this
gives the intervention and a break on
proceedings to enable um particular
consideration to be given to whatever
technical legal constitutional or other
considerations should be brought to bear
on the matter and the matter brought
back to a committee at a later
date to avoid delay probably at a
special meeting of the relevant
committee um that can be reconvened at
an earlier date um to to finally
determine the matter but I would just um
emphasize that um the the working group
wanted out of all of the options for
dealing with this intervention or break
for the option involving deferment to be
the preferred one and that is indeed in
the recommendation in this
report uh the second item is uh the
introduction of technical briefings and
presentations on uh
applications um to be used fairly um
rarely I think has been concluded this
will be a separate separately organized
briefing and
presentation um by officers to members
of the relevant planning committee on
particular complex and technical issues
um this will not in any way take the
place of or be extra to what will be
available and uh provided to members at
the committee meeting itself but it
gives another opportunity for members to
look at uh particular issues arising
from a complex of technical
application uh in appendix a to this
report there are some
guidelines around how this should
happen and again Um this can be weaved
into the
Constitutional arrangements for the
workings of the committee or the
operational protocol for the Committees
um and for that reason um in both cases
the the working group have commended
this to the committee for onward
reference to
council VI the governance and Order
committee simply to consider and
formulate the Constitutional
implications thank you uh thank you Mr
Jennings
um I'm minded that um there's going to
be a lot of discussion about this uh and
particular with the Advent of our our
guest tonight and so one thing I want to
just
establish is um a bit of the
practicalities about this particularly
in the way that this break is going to
be exercised I mean so are we having a
situation where in a par in a planning
committee if um after the discussions
have been happened does the chairman
then call if if for example the
recommendation is for refusal does you
say call that are the is the committee
minded to approve this and a show of
hands is then given and at that moment
that is when the break will be
instituted is that sort of how we see
that that's sort of how you saw it being
being
exercised I guess so chairman there
there would have to be a
clear mindset of the of the committee um
to go against the officer's
recommendation now whether that is um a
general indication from views expressed
around the table or from a proposition
that is made um but of course um there
won't be a decision at that point it it
will be a minded two so this will this
will actually break the uh the
proceedings before a final decision is
made so yes um it it is AED two
position right okay thank you so opening
yes Council
Moy um yeah I'm just trying to
understand this so it really is if we go
against the officer's
decision if you're if we're minded to if
we're minded to I'm trying to you know
put it in plain English on um is is
there a a cost to this then for the the
council to go over it again and what
what is the period of of well that's
very good question I supp that's are we
are we then going to add another cost
which the
council obviously doesn't need well
obviously there would need to be another
meeting yes and and then what happens
when it comes back and we still well
agree with our decision the the
presumably the advice would have been
given and it's then a question of
whether the committee is continuing to
be to don't just be minded but to
actually vote so how many how many goes
do you get at it that's just the one all
right okay yeah it's just a yeah no I
appreciate
that thank
you and
um I would say that um two things occur
to me really reading this again and I
think the more times you read it
probably the more things occur to you
but um with regard to um being minded to
O overturn an officer's decision
constitutionally could we possibly have
would there be an option whereby the
committee could
decide whether they wanted to go down
the Constitutional break route or not if
you you see what I mean so I can think
of
examples um where we there were members
who were minded to want to deferral
because of of the seriousness of the
situation so that it could be reexamined
and others where where members were very
very sure about what they wanted um
regardless of that so that's just
something that that I would wonder
whether that was possible
constitutionally for the committee to
have that as an option rather than it
would automatic go to constitutional
break so that the Constitutional break
would be optional depending on on on the
situation and the other thing was just
some clarity around so one of the things
particularly on more minor applications
um I have seen as others would have done
is where um an officer recommendation is
overturned so that we approve rather
than refuse and obviously I wouldn't
particularly see the point in those um
well I think that that would be probably
very unwise for numerous reasons to to
have a any kind of constitutional break
when it's the other way around and
that's I it just occurred to me that
that's not 100% clear in the
report so th just those two points
really thank
you Council Moy yeah just if IU can just
come back I think we can defer anyway
can't we we we've got that the
constitution um is and also is is there
a model of this being done in other
committees other councils yeah yes there
is there is that that was right I think
we produced um examples did we not
Stewart in the previously did you not
come forward with some other examples of
that where that has happened in other in
other councils not not so much examples
CH but I mean this this is drawn from
yeah sort of similar s of
practices but it's very difficult to
draw um clear comparisons because of the
differ structures in committe structures
in place authorties all
right councilor white did you thank you
Mr chairman for allowing me to speak and
and allowing me at your committee um
basic I've got a few questions um the
first one is that um I've read this that
the reason for it is to reduce costs
when appeals are allowed um and i' I've
been searching today and I've got a
whole load of them here and the majority
of overturns committees are for
approvals and most of them barring a
couple of anom anomalies where the costs
have been allowed has been the major
planning applications well for me those
large planning applications we have
great big long technal reports officers
do long reports before the meetings so
to defer it again it means that all the
big applications that we may have turned
down they'd have to come back again for
another go and I know at North West when
we've deferred meetings they've come
back and actually we've been more more
unanimous the second time around out of
anger that that officers refuse to issue
the decision notice so they already do
this and they already have the option to
do it um so um basically if we approve
the large apps what you're saying is
they will it will have to go to another
committee which surely is going to have
a cost um we can already defer decisions
to another committee Southeast recently
did this um so it's already in the
Constitution um so you're well the other
thing is um has already been touched on
you're saying that if we disagree with
officers it will have to be referred to
another meeting well what's the cost of
this because they're already officers
are already trying to say we don't want
area planning committees because they're
do too expensive so I estimate at
Northwest every time we have a meeting
there will be several more meetings
following that meeting when we've
overturned the officer's decision to
approve like pearly barns which we
approved they refused to issue the
decision notice for another month clarem
Garden Center was another one that they
refused to issue the decision notice
because they didn't want a cafe at a
garden center um so how many how much is
all these additional meetings going to
cost and can everybody who works get to
them um so you know why can't we retain
the status quo um and the other thing is
for me as an elected member the main
thing people are interested in is
planning whether people vote for you or
against you and lastly there's been a
very recent judicial review and I know
this personally in the last few weeks
with Molen District Council and they
were advised by Simon quelch and the
head of planning that an application
could not be determined under Section
73a however a barrister did a judicial
review and immediately they received
that judicial review molden District
Council rolled over and had to pay costs
on that decision so how do we know that
the legal decisions we're getting are
going to be correct and accurate I mean
for me I'm interested how those
questions answered but for me we're on
here as Democratic elected people and as
far as I'm concerned mostly we overturn
to approve at Northwest but if we do
refuse a big application we do it for
the best reasons hand on heart because
we think it's the best decision and to
take away that democracy to me I just
does not sit well and it's it's why I've
come here tonight when I saw this on the
agenda thank you okay yes okay so
um the reason that this was brought
forward was um following um a request by
um Council fluka actually looking at
decisions that were made and
particularly um around um a decision
where um the council incurred very heavy
um costs and I think and I could be
corrected if I'm wrong because I wasn't
a member then but um my understanding is
that um that came from a decision that
was made and then there was a further
discussion and advice and the committee
then agreed that that application could
be approved but the because the because
the decision had already been made or
issued it couldn't be withdrawn and
therefore the developer still went ahead
with the appeal and I think we all know
the one I'm talking about and therefore
a lot of money was lost so I think
that's where in looking at all this from
and I remember this from last year this
is where the um constitutional break
idea came I see it slightly different
personally from a deferment because I
think the and I understand we already
have um the possibility of defer when I
was talking about it being optional I
know we already have that option to
defer but this was something a bit
stronger I think in terms of getting the
advice uh on whether or not you know
what the implications would be um and
what I was trying to say was if members
were absolutely minded that whatever the
implications were then maybe that could
be overridden but I can think of at
least one case where me some members
quite a few members I think were worried
that they weren't fully um sure you know
sure about what the implications were
but it does take you know it is on on
the report we do look at the fact that
we shouldn't be taking into
account some of the implications only
the planning
only in terms of um planning law so it
is it is
complex um but I do take that that's
just really giving background for why
we're looking at it it you know and
that's why the status quo has been
examined was because members raised that
as a as a concern thank
you
anybody I'm just thinking Mr Jennings
that we probably need my thoughts are
members can decide is that we probably
need a bit more work on this in terms of
actually bottoming out the
practicalities the practical way that
this would work um before we we decide I
decid to send it I be I'm happy to send
it if everyone wants to do it now but I
I think there's a little bit more to to
be done on this in terms of the
detail I I just wonder if it's worth the
separating out the um the part where
we're looking at the technical
presentations and taking that forward
now and then doing some more work
possibly on the deferment because the
technical presentations are separate
from that and I'm not sure that they're
as controversial are they because it's
just about members having more
information it's just a
thought uh well just I think hopefully
got the procedure right I'm presuming I
think we want to perhaps put the um the
current the Cent current recommendation
that we get send to send this as it
currently stands to
pgna does every any every those in
favor those
against right good so do we have a uh my
proposal that uh which well I I now
propose that this go back and be
deferred for further discussion yeah um
do I have a second yeah
I'll so on that basis do I have a those
in favor
those against right thank you that
carried right Mr JS and then I think in
the course of doing that we can consider
before going forward as to whether we as
you say separate those two yeah okay
thank you all
right so uh moving
on uh
agenda uh item
seven uh scrutiny work plan item on
planning enforcement Pages 15 and 16 16
of the report again Mr Jennings um you
want to introduce
this yes chairman thank you the um the
working group um have uh and the
committee have over several months um
been looking at planning enforcement as
a scrutin work plan item and have
received a lot of data information and
explanations um on
resourcing um process
and performance and gradually over that
period I think it's fair to say and
hopefully this report reflects what the
working group at least uh have felt that
um things are on a much better track now
particularly on uh on resources and
performance um to the point where um not
having identified any particular area
that requires detailed
scrutiny this item can at least be
removed from the scrutiny work plan but
nevertheless um kept on as a watching
brief um for periodic review by the
working group
um particularly having regard to the
impending um we're drafting in
consideration of the planning
enforcement polic which obvious working
group and your committee will wish to
have a close involvement with it so
that's essentially the recommendation
reflecting the uh the considered of the
work thank you so we have a
recommendations anyone have anything
they want to add to that councilor
Stevens thank you I'm not quite clear
how this sort of working what's it
called a working brief will really work
will we have this on the agenda every
time that we look at it or something I
think otherwise it's just going to get
lost and forgotten I it's either got to
be on an agenda to keep an eye on it or
it's not and then it won't get watched
and I say that particularly because we
all we used to get um oh I can't
remember a monthly bulletin I suppose on
enforcement um and we had a long time
when there weren't when enforcements
weren't being done and we now have
access to the Phoenix mapping and I have
a diary entry to look at that every
month the same as I used to look at the
report that came every month fine but
the mapping only shows me what's been
closed up to or since May or something
there's a fixed date which was May this
year and that date never moves so to
start with it was it was interesting and
useful but the further away from may we
go the less useful that is so I can't
any longer really see what's progressing
but I know from conversations with
planning enforcement that things are
progressing but I can't see it so I'm
not quite clear how we can keep a
watching brief thank you
okay so I I think one of the important
things I mean I I I agree actually um
councilor Steven so I think we would
need to make sure that this did come
back and I know when we had um and um
Miss Hughes might be able to help me
here when we had um a watching brief on
um Parks the parks department that that
did come back um periodically with a
report so I think maybe we'd have to set
some sort of boundary on on how how
often it came back as maybe maybe I
would I would suggest as part of the
motion that we we look at um look at
altering um it to to suggest a time
frame for how often it comes back um
with a report to us so that would then
keep that um going but also I think it
I'm slightly concerned because the
important point with regard to the
planning enforcement policy was us being
able to take part in the review and I'm
a little bit worried that that might get
lost um because if if you recall members
and I don't you know not all members
will recall this um but the ones that
were here one of the things that we
looked at um was time frames around
various types of enforcement so for
example things that are Urgent and what
the expectation would be so if we're
looking at trees or listed buildings and
the current enforcement policy
um wasn't where it should be with regard
to that um so I think um and actually
we've got a little note
there um so so I I think that it would
be it would be good to have some sort of
frame time frame around when we're
actually having this brought back so
that it doesn't just vanish I
agree yeah thank you I mean um Mr joh
Jenny how would you see a watch I mean
you the watching brief actually operate
as such
well the watching brief is is exactly
that for the committee or the working
group to make up it um to to decide how
how it wishes to give it under regular
review um and then having done that the
the the working group and then reporting
periodically to the committee can
receive the same level of information or
targeted information that it has um
enjoyed receiving in in the recent past
so um all I would say is the working
group is meeting a lot more regularly
than it was done uh that it had
previously so perhaps on a monthly basis
um might be unduly um Regular um unless
it was a particular thing that the
members wish to keep a a regular eye on
so it really is we're in MERS hands on
that moment right thank you yep counc St
thank you I I think considering what
councelor spencley has just said
quarterly sounds good but actually I
think that's too far apart and things
will just get lost um we've got the
mapping but that doesn't give you the
metrics for the for the whole District
if you look at the whole District all
you're seeing is just lots of dots on a
map if you zoom into your own area
obviously you can focus a bit more and
it's you can get more of an
understanding of your own Ward but I
don't have a picture anymore of how good
or bad we the situation is and I think
I'd like to see some statistics at every
meeting really a brief report showing
how many new enforcements are now on the
list how many have been
closed because we couldn't do anything
about them because we'd let too much
time elapse how many have been closed
because we successfully enforced that
sort of thing doesn't need to be a great
detailed report just at least some
numbers um would be helpful thank you um
Mr w I think you want to come in
and talk about the the mapping in
specifically well yes thank you chair um
uh the um just a clarification on the
how frequently the enforcement
application is
updated and I can see why there is a
confusion because when I just checked
following what council Steven said I was
also confused uh from that um so the
enforcement data I have checked with um
Miss off Shand as well the enforcement
data on the mapping system is updated
daily from uh the from uniform which is
the planning management taste management
system that manages the enforcement
applications that planning enforcement
use um uh so um it is um it's updated
Monday to Friday obviously there's a lag
over anything that's received in over
the weekend bit time to get that on um
and um so and if if there is a if there
is any misunderstanding on that we can
get some communication out to all
members just um reminding that that
information is updated more more
frequently um in respects if I may chair
in respects of the suggestion that's
just com in about some more um I suppose
more pertinent um information about how
General planning enforcement is going in
terms of the metrics of it really that
of course is something which we can
provide um uh is relatively easy for us
to do so um there's no sort of pressing
issues with that so you would be quite
capable of producing on a on a monthly
basis a report that could be considered
by the working groups
Etc uh yeah we we can do the monthly
whether you see too
much
okay uh cancel white thank you Mr
chairman um yeah mine really is that um
gosh about 12 years ago we used to have
a monthly uh enforcement update or
certainly quarterly enforcement update
and as members we could call to the end
of the planning committee anything that
we were particularly concerned about in
our Ward and we'd go through those in
detail um and the other thing I wanted
to say is do we still have the harm
Matrix and I actually emailed Richard
Holmes to tell him I was coming tonight
um because of an issue that's in my ward
and I'm going to bore you with a little
story about it in
2012 kismi kebabs um had built loads of
illegal buildings nothing had planning
and they came to us and said we're
really sorry we don't understand English
planning laws if you approve this we'll
we'll approve the whole thing so we did
approve it we approved all these legal
buildings that was fine 2015 they
applied for an accommodation block which
got refused and then in
2021 um we had an application come to
Northwest that was to approve um an
accommodation block that had no planning
three or four other buildings that had
no planning but but the worst thing when
I'm get to the harm cancel sorry I fully
understand the situation but I don't
think this is actually appropriate but
what I wanted to get to is the that that
this has been going on all this time and
it said if we approved it they would fix
the main problem and what it was there's
a fan that discharged into the
residential garden and it has a noise
abatement order it failed the noise test
and it's it's really stinky and goes
into a residential garden and they could
easily rot it and so far they hav't done
sorry I don't think it's appropriate to
go into an individual case do we still
have the harm when when I'm when they
look at um enforcement do they take the
harm into account because nothing's
happened with this since
2021 uh well I think that's a matter for
Mr Winslow can you comment on that
so in terms of the harm Matrix um sort
of principle um this will be coming
through the updated enforcement policy
because obviously that is what um that's
what members will apply when they're
determining uh which um uh which
breaches or potential breaches of
planning control uh various sort of
forms of action should be taken again so
in terms of uh so that's being uh
written at the moment and we hope uh
that the enforcement obviously will be
um with bers for discussion through the
work groups early next year thank
you right members therefore on that
basis the recommendation is that it be
dropped out any watching brief be
continued is uh is that
agreed yeah good right good moving
on to
um right the next uh agenda
item8 uh muted secruity request molden
citizens advice again Mr Jennings are
you going to can you lead us in on this
or is
it very briefly chairman um this is a
matter um which the uh committee uh and
through its working group took up as a
result of um a member request um care of
yourself chairman um asking to look at
certain issues arising from um a visit
and some discussions with um the
citizens advice uh at the time
um more recently the working group had a
very detailed report on um it's the
involvement of this council with that
body um and some financial implications
were of particular interest to the um
working group
and the result is that it's been
commended to this committee um to onward
commend to council um um what the finan
financial implications of of the
contractual arrangement with uh MCR are
and the excellent value of the money
delivered by way of supporting a wide
range of council Services the principal
reason for
all the information which is contained
in the append to this report to council
is that the contract is due to be
reviewed early next year and the uh
working group feel that there is much
here to be born in mind when that is
done and the point of this report is to
endorse the conclusions of the working
group and refer it to council thank you
Miss Green do you want to comment come
in on that as
all thank you chairman hope hopefully
the the report that we provide to the
working group gives a very clear picture
of the very high value um that the
citizens advice provides both for the
council and also for the Council
taxpayers of the district um we've
recently had of some some further
information from them um in terms of uh
sort of the total numbers they have
assisted and I don't know if that would
help um the committee just to put into
context some of the support that they
provide so for the last Financial year
um over 3,000 local residents were
assisted with 12,000 separate
issues um they the citizens ADV assisted
our local residents um to obtain 1.7
million additional income through
various um opportunities including
additional
benefits they assisted nearly 500 people
who were in pel poverty they supported
850 res
to access online
services uh they assisted 238 people
where they were presenting as
homeless um probably one of the really
key things for us is the fact that um
for last year the level of funding that
both us and ess6 County Council provided
um amounted to 33% of their um total
cost of running service um so 2third of
the cost of service um is to external
funding or
fundraising now that compares with 10
years ago um where the citizen ofice
were relying on 90 0% of their funding
was provided either by this Council or
's County Council so um in the course of
10 years they have worked really hard to
reduce their Reliance on funding
directly from local authorities and find
other sources of funding which I think
is very commendable so hopefully members
that that will assist the committee and
in considering the the recommendations
in thank you um right members so we have
the recommendation little one uh that
the committee endorses the conclusions
of its working group and refers to the
council the findings of the scrutiny as
detailed in the briefing paper at
appendix a to the report and little two
that member's attention is drawn to the
financial implications of the
contractual arrangement with uh molden
citizens advis and the excellent value
for money delivered by way of supporting
a wide range of council services so that
this is born in mind when the contract
is reviewed next year is that
agreed
okay okay uh moving
on to agenda item nine future health
provision in molden and the proposed new
molden health Hub um just to give a bit
of context to this um there used to be
specific overview and scrutiny meetings
set for partner challenge including uh
National Health Service and Health but
these have not taken place for some time
um it is in with within the terms of
reference of the committee to receive
reports and other evidence from public
bodies organizations and individuals
which the committee or a working group
considers relevant to its
work um now uh Council SP and I have
became aware that members concerns have
been raised particularly around the loss
of healthc care provision and Future
Health provision coming forwards for the
district um and it is felt this
committee can provide a forum for
members concerns to be raised and
updated reports on this subject to be
received and so both myself and the vice
chair would like to seek uh your
approval committee approval to add this
as a work plan item and suggest that we
V invite the NHS onto the next working
group meeting to highlight the
information we would like and set up an
additional extraordinary meeting of the
overview uh scrutiny committee focusing
on health
scrutiny is this
agreed thank you
good Stevens sorry oh sorry councelor
Stevens thank you yes I do agree but I
just wanted to ask a question please if
I may so we've uh had a couple of
meetings with the NHS recently and I
just wondered if that will now become
part of this or is that going to carry
on separately CU that would seem a bit
dared if it
carried think my view is it would that
would be the main way of doing it but
yeah that's uh uh my understanding
certainly Mr Donley was yeah was looking
forward to coming and speaking to us
thank
you right okay so moving on to item
10 uh scrutiny work plan item the cyber
security update that's Pages 23 and
24 uh of the report again Mr Jennings
can you take us to
it yes chairman this was originally uh
brought to uh this committee on
reference from the performance
governance and audit committee back in
September last year uh with with a
request that the audit and Technical
reports available at that time be
reviewed um the committee uh agreed to
add it to its scrutiny work plan and in
March um having seen the uh the
technical reports and uh audit reports
and the schedules of the progress made
in a number of detailed areas at that
time um f agreed to accept by way of
reassurance the update um but it was
known at that time that there were
matters still to come forward in a
pending internal audit report and of
course as this report indicates time has
moved on with this and as recently as
the 16th of November the performance
governance and AIT committee uh received
an internal report in audit report on
this
and um apart from a couple of other
matters updated a couple of matters
which were updated at the meeting um it
was noted at the PGA committee that the
council uh had substantial Assurance on
cyber security so and it details those
other matters which were were dealt with
and updated at the time so I think this
report essentially uh marks time on on
something that was added to the scrutiny
work plan over a year ago um um and
really reassurance has been provided
through um the work done at the outset
and the internal AIT report um submitted
to the BJ Committee in November so
unless there's anything that this
committee uh wishes to identify and seek
further scrutiny on then I think time
has passed passed by and the the matter
of cyber security deleted from work plan
at this
time thank you Mr Jenning so members the
recommendation is that the cyber
security be deleted from the scrutiny
work plan does is that
approved good
okay so uh moving on to agenda item 11
scrutiny work plan item safeguarding of
children and vulnerable adults corporate
risk update and we're delighted to see
Mr Geller here to can give us thank you
his report thank you members um just to
provide a quick update uh in relation to
the work plan so just to give a bit of
context so in October 2022 M District
Council underwent a follow-up
safeguarding audit there was a previous
one in July 2020 now the followup review
ranged from our general safeguarding
activities to a small number of reviews
on our cases and at the conclusion the
following um recommendations were made
that the council ensure that it
maintains a list of volunteer
organizations that the council compile
list of contractors that all required
attendees to The safeguarding Forum be
reminded of their duties to attend to
introduce an action tracker to the
safeguarding meeting and to update the
safeguarding policy designated
safeguarding officer list and to
regularly review on an annual basis to
safeguarding policy so by way of update
I can say that with points one and and
two so that's the volunteer
organizations and the uh list of
contractors a volunteers list and a
contractor's list has been set up with
advice from on procurement officers
across the council can now access that
um spreadsheet to maintain and update
the list uh with overall responsibility
resting with departmental managers
safeguarding lead so that would be
myself uh engages with the volunteer
agencies and contractors to check their
own safeguarding processes if they have
one for themselves if not that they
should adopt our
one in terms of point three so requiring
all attendees to The safeguarding Forum
to be reminded of their responsibilities
to attend
now this is partly the reason why the
this action came to
on um there was previous there was a
large number of designated safeguarding
officers and because there was a large
number of designated safeguarding
officers attendance at the safeguarding
Forum tended to be low and so because of
that I raised the uh risk likelihood by
one point from one to two and and as a
result that's how it came to ons in the
first place um we've now updated the
designated safeguarding officers list
and I've also changed it slightly so
that it's now a teered system so all the
designated safeguarding officers are
trained to a more senior level uh tier
one officers are the ones that required
to attend the safeguarding meetings
allowing for sickness and annual leave
the tier 2 officers can attend on a more
ad hoc basis that frees up a bit more
time now this approach is obviously
reduced Staffing demand for the
safeguarding Forum uh and it allows a
number of of key officers to to attend
as when they need to as opposed to being
required to do so and there's also a
renewed understanding now of who the
designated safeguarding officers are now
monitoring this over the past couple of
forums uh and the next one pending if
the attendance Still Remains positive
I'll be reducing that likelihood from
two back down to
one in terms of introducing an action
tracker to the safeguarding meeting that
was very easy to do and has been done
and it's uh it's been in place since
August and it's referenced at all the
safeguarding meetings that are
occurring in terms of updating the
designated safeguarding officers list
I've said that's been done but also to
review the safeguarding policy regularly
um I can assure that um the safeguarding
Strate policy is discussed regularly at
The safeguarding Forum what can be
improved what do we need to be mindful
of um having said that the safeguarding
uh policy does need to be refreshed and
and that's work that I've got planned
for
2425 um just some other quick notes for
your own benefit um our our back office
system management is working well and
it's allowing officers to quickly review
action and close uh any safeguarding
referrals made to give you an indication
we've had 62 safeguarding referrals over
the last 6 months all of which have been
handled processed and
closed um in terms of the safeguarding
meeting attendance again just for
information um the October meeting we
had six out of the nine tier one
officers and again at uh the meeting
that was on the 6th of the 12th so
yesterday uh there was also six out of
nine there uh so for me the Safeguard
audit conditions have been satisfied as
as best they can and for me it moves on
to business as usual uh the next points
of work for me to refresh the
safeguarding policy there's some extra
training uh for staff around some of the
forms that we use and I'm looking to try
and update the internet and with with a
couple of supporting bits of information
that can a decision making so that's
where we are with the safeguarding work
uh thank you Mr G in terms of Staffing
levels are you happy that you you're
sort of got enough people to do what
needs to be done yes absolutely I think
the problem was before it was almost too
wide right and so that's where some of
the the issues were with attendance but
now that it's been made more concise and
split into teers that that gives a lot
more clarity
okay Council
spency so just a couple of things thanks
for the update Mr Geller so um it was
highlighted before an audit wasn't it
that we had as you say we had we had an
issue and to my mind one of the issues
came around staff moving on so churn and
keeping um an eye on so do we now have a
procedure in place to make sure that
when somebody leaves that's dealt with
um we do okay and and the other thing
was um can you remind me because with
regard to the safeguarding policy it was
due for an update wasn't it and and I
think we were overdue with that update
am I right was it was it that we were
supposed to have an update by now so the
policy currently has the original date
when it was the one on the on the
internet says 2020 um now we like I said
we review it all the safeguarding
meetings that the topic of the policy
comes up uh it is due for me as a for
proper refresh um like I said work for
next year I don't think we're over time
on it as far as I'm but I will double
thank you uh councelor White I'm sorry
Mr chairman I just like say Mr Gill that
was a a really good piece of work and a
lot of maturity work I do I actually
work with vulnerable people so that's
really good news and I'd like to say two
things really one is thank you so much
for taking the time to turn up in person
as a member I really appreciate that it
just shows that you're committed and and
just to say again that we really are I'm
sure members I speak for all of them
that we really do appreciate the work
you and Mr swords do and we're lucky to
have both you as officers here at molden
so thank you very much here here uh
Council Moy yes I'd like to thank you as
well because time and time again we hear
the expression which I hate you know
lessons will be learned and things like
that and I just hate that and I like to
think with the safeguarding officers and
I do remember this about who who checks
them as well you I I know how far could
you go but no brilliant if you you can
keep that up that that's good cuz I hate
that expression lessons will be learned
and it's tragic you know thank
you councilor Steven sorry chair I think
we ought to sa for the record in view of
what we've just heard that there isn't a
safeguarding issue that's happened we
haven't had a child safety incident or
something like that it was around
managing risks and potential things and
not an actual incident just want to
clarify that
please good
point right thank you Mr Keller thank
you very much
indeed so uh
right so I think that brings us to item
12 any other items of business the
chairperson committee decides our Ur
which I have none unless anyone else has
got anything they want to bring up in
which case I thank you for your
attendance and declare the meeting
closed as at
0820 thank you
babers